مع استمرار ضربات جيشها لمواقع ما تعرفه
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال الشرقيه
سوريا واحتمال شنه عمليه عسكريه بريه تفتح
تركيا الباب امام حلول توقف معها عمليتها
العسكريه البريه المحتمله المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم اوضح شروط بلاده
بان ينسحب المسلحون الاكراد الى عمق 30 كم
بعيدا عن الحدود مع تركيا مصادر رسميه
تركيه قالت بالجزيره ان الجانب الروسي هو
من يسعى لتهدئه الاوضاع وانما تطلبه انقره
والسحابه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
في تلك المناطق مؤسسات النظام السوري
الامنيه وحرس حدوده بديلا من المسلحين
الاكراد
قائد ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ابدى مخاوفا من بدي هجوم بري تركي رغم ما
وصفها بتطميات واشنطن ومرد ذلك ما قال انه
استمرار تركيا في حشد مزيد من قواتها عند
الحدود في الوقت نفسه فان المسؤولين
الاتراك شددوا على ان جيش بلادهم سينفذ
هجوما بريا يحقق فيه امن الحدود الجنوبيه
لتركيا وذلك في حال عدم تنفيذ المسلحين
الاكراد لشروط انقره تجدر الاشاره اخيرا
الى ان معطيات شمال الشرقيه
تشابهما حدث عام 2019 من الاتفاق الروسيين
تركيين في سوتشي تضمن وقتها انسحاب
المسلحين الاكراد وابتعادهم عن الحدود
وحلول قوات النظام السوري مكانهم وهو ما
لم ينفذ وفق المسؤولين الاتراك مع فريق
واحد هو ان اتفاق سوتشي جاء بعد عمليه
عسكريه بريه تركيه
[موسيقى]